for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so if you recall the purpose of the urea
cycle was to safely rid the body of
excess ammonium ion because it is toxic
right so and of course the the urea
cycle requires properly functioning urea
cycle enzymes because those enzymes are
would actually allow the processing of
that excess ammonium ion so what if
someone has a deficiency in one or more
of those enzymes well that's a problem
because that means that that person
cannot properly get rid of ammonium ion
and that would mean that there would be
an increase in the concentration of NH 4
plus in the blood which is called hyper
ammonia which is really really bad and
dangerous and it's potentially lethal so
is it possible to determine which
specific enzyme or enzymes are deficient
if so how well the answer the first part
is yes and if so how well the
intermediate prior to that ends on that
deficient enzyme will build up so what
does that mean let's use an example here
are Gino succinate is an intermediate of
the urea cycle right here so let's say
that there's a buildup of large enough
succinate so we have an increased
concentration of our Gino succinate an
abnormal increase in concentration that
means that there is a deficiency or a
low amount of our Gino succinate that's
this enzyme right because this is the
enzyme that's supposed to process our
Gino succinate what was so what's the
deal here basically our Gino succinate
building up means that it's not going
through in the the urea cycle pathway
it's not going through to produce
arginine in fumarate
why isn't it going through well because
there's a deficiency in the enzyme that
acts on
this enzyme is what's supposed to allow
our Gino succinate to be converted into
our G and in fumarate but if that enzyme
is deficient or that means that there's
not enough of it around to process the
are Gino succinate that's there okay so
the intermediate prior to this enzyme so
this is the enzyme that we're talking
about the intermediate prior to it right
before it is Arjun or succinate that's
how you can identify a deficiency in one
of those enzymes and that could apply
for these other enzymes here so can
patients with these types of disorders
be treated with diets free of protein or
free of a nitrogen source the answer is
no because there are these things called
essential amino acids essential amino
acids that are necessary to consume for
survival the essential amino acids are
basically amino acids that your body
cannot synthesize the non-essential
amino acids are amino acids that your
body can synthesize so essential amino
acids are amino acids that you must
consume in your diet because you do need
all 20 amino acids in order to survive
but the essential ones you can't
actually make them yourself so you have
to eat them so having a diet free of
protein or free of nitrogen would be
free of essential amino acids which
would be bet that that means survival is
not possible by the way nothing I say in
this video should be taken to be medical
advice it's all approached strictly from
an academic perspective so if you have
any questions about any of this that
it's not from an academic perspective
you're looking for medical advice please
go see your doctor okay so some people
might say this and think okay which s n
which amino acids are the essential ones
well back in the day one of my
biochemistry classes I had a TA who came
up with this milk for watching TV which
is kind of weird but each underlined
letter is the one letter code for the
amino acid that's essential
so the essential amino acids are mi LK
which is both ie or which are defining
isoleucine leucine lysine and an F
phenylalanine the W and watching is
tripped
than H and watching is histidine and T
and V are threatening and valine so it's
kind of weird
milk for watching TV I don't drink milk
when I watch TV but the point is I use
this to remember and I haven't forgotten
so it might be good for you to remember
this anyway so if we can't treat these
patients with with diets for your
protein what then are the treatments for
patients with these types of disorders
let's see here basically when it comes
to these treatments they focus on
basically getting rid of excess nitrogen
which is basically doing the job of the
urea cycle without the actual urea cycle
so one treatment option is low protein
diets and the idea behind that is simply
that there's less nitrogen intake right
which means that there's less of a need
for the urea cycle which means it's less
likely that ammonium ion concentrations
will get too high because just because
one of the enzymes in the urea cycle is
deficient doesn't mean that the urea
cycle cannot happen just can't happen to
a great extent so you can still get some
protein just not too much making it the
workload for the urea cycle is not too
high so less nitrogen in less of a need
for the urea cycle and the deficiency is
seemingly less detrimental ok there's
also the option of administering
benzoate or phenyl butyrate and what
these guys do is they basically pick up
amino acids and of course amino acids
have nitrogen on them and they take them
to the urine to be excreted which forces
a cell to remake them using the excess
ammonium ion in the blood and cells so
what does that mean well let's take what
I've drawn here and figure it out
benzoate specifically excretes glycine
and so if cells respond by making more
glycine using ammonium ion that's freely
floating so what's going on with bent
away well this is benzoate here verted
it's a benzoyl co way by adding coenzyme
a and some ATP and benzoyl co is co a
here
is going to be replaced by glycine and
we get benzoyl glycine or HIPAA rate and
what's important about this molecule is
that it can be safely excreted in the
urine what else has have we said can be
safely excreted in the urine
well urea right we had those nitrogens
attached to it and that's the safe way
that we can get rid of nitrogen benzoyl
glycine this nitrogen right here is
being safely excreted so basically
what's happening is that this molecule
is doing the job that that urea pretty
much does okay by getting rid of that
nitrogen so it except it's not just the
nitrogen it's a whole amino acid with
glycine so if glycine is basically being
taken away from this cell and the cell
has to response kind of like hey you're
taking mike lysine well I can't do
anything about it I guess I have to make
more glycine using the excess ammonia
that's around which will end up
decreasing the concentration of ammonium
ion that's around federal butyrate does
pretty much the same thing except with a
different amino acid it does it with
glutamine so it excretes glutamine and
the cells respond by making more
glutamine again using the NH 4 plus it's
around so this is phenol butyrate here
we'll add a coenzyme a an acetyl co a
comes off turning that phenol butyrate
into phenol acetate right here and we'll
add a coenzyme a and some ATP these
details aren't that important to me I
don't know if they're important to you
so don't take that and you like the
wrong way if anyway this phenol acetyl
co way the co a group right here is
replaced with glutamine and that would
mean is now attached here and we have
phenol acetyl glutamine which like HIPAA
rate or benzoyl lysine can be safely
excreted in the urine and it's going to
take these two nitrogens with it so the
cell has to respond after upon losing
this glutamine it has to respond by
making more glutamine to account for
that loss and it's going to use the
excess ammonium ion in order to do that
so the overall effect
administering these drugs is to decrease
the nitrogen levels which like I said
it's basically the doing the job of the
urea cycle without the actual urea cycle
anyway I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying